okay let's talk about elon musk and what
he said about the tax bill that's coming
up uh that they're pushing so elon musk
rips democrats billionaire tax plan that
could slap him with a 10 billion dollar
annual bill this is an insider story on
monday he criticized the democratic tax
proposal that would target american
billionaires to fund a safety net
expansion saying it represented the
start of a new campaign from democrats
to redistribute wealth from the richest
americans eventually they run out of
other people's money and then they come
for you he wrote on twitter in a
separate tweet musk said any any
government induced
reallocation of wealth would be better
managed by the private sector who is
best at capital allocation government or
entrepreneurs is indeed what it comes
down to must could face up to 50 billion
in taxes for the first five years under
the plan if implemented and i'll
continue for the next story as well and
then we'll talk about it
cnn this is another story two percent of
elon musk's wealth uh would save world
hunger says the director of u.n food
scarcity organization uh billionaires
need to step up now on a one-time basis
said the director of united nations
world food program citing specifically
the world's two richest man jeff bezos
six billion dollars to help 42 million
people that are literally going to die
if we don't reach them it's not
complicated musk has a net worth of 289
meaning that the beasley is asking for a
donation of just two percent of his
fortune the net worth of u.s
billionaires has almost doubled since
the pandemic began standing at five
trillion dollars in october so thoughts
danielle i'm going to go to you first
with what elon said about the 10 billion
dollar tax bill per year and
redistributing the wealth
so i mean you know there are
there are two sides to this story right
uh and part of it has to do with the
fact that as a country
we haven't really paid attention to the
disparity for way too long between ceo
pay and worker pay so there's something
to be said for if you've got a great
employee pay the great employee what
they're worth and that hasn't happened
for a long time and the way that
shareholder value is
is formed the way that ceos get
compensated
you know the value of of their stock
holdings um you know it it it does look
like everything is going into more and
more fewer and fewer hands
so
but
but to say that somebody who's created
all of these jobs
needs to be taxed to kingdom come
instead of
let let charity be charitable look at
look at
what some of these foundations have done
around the world in terms of medicine
health care a lot of these people are
very charitable if they're not
fine but trying to go after just a few
individuals is is kind of short-sighted
in my view because a lot of these people
are heroes to young american kids and
they aspire to grow
and be entrepreneurs like them are they
though because
you know uh
each generation to me whoever is in
power in politics can
uh read dictate who
what a hero looks like and it confuses
the hell out of kids so yeah yeah if
you're if you're jing ping and you're
jack ma but we're not that kind of a guy
wait a minute but wait a minute go to
berkeley go to a columbia university go
to i'm a 19 year old kid going to school
do you really think 80 percent of
professors are selling elon musk as a
hero
do you think do you think do you think
professors at these universities are
saying you ought to grow up and be like
elon musk and jeff bezos or do you think
they're saying you ought to grow up and
be like aoc and you know you ought to
grow up and be somebody that's giving
back you ought to grow up what do you
think they're selling as a hero so the
kid
as a as a if you ever watch the parents
who raise kids who win if you're around
the parents long enough
obviously some of the credit goes to the
kids which is half the credit is kids
because the kids are the ones that are
going to go to work but the other half
is what is the moment that's selling as
success
is it money is it who you are as a
leader is it giving back is it you know
making the world a better place is it
creating jobs is it creating economy is
it finding your passion it's
independence independent i'm okay
perfect so that's do you really think
that's what's being sold as hero no no
well then that's the problem so elon
musk today is not a hero
to 90 percent of academia danielle
90 of academia but you have to know that
it's like you know you know a funnel
right you know a funnel like what does a
funnel look like it looks like something
like this okay all right so we're going
through what you know k through
12 you know whatever you want to put a k
through six and then you got middle and
then you got junior high and then you
got high school and then you got college
and then you got career right i'm going
through this funnel well at this funnel
here when i get to the college side 90
of them are going to demonize ilama so
the kid is going to say screw this elon
musk guy why should he be so rich the
hell with jeff bezos the hell would
buffet the hell with bill gates these
guys are a bunch of schmucks and greedy
people okay so i i've got my oldest is
applying to college right now and
berkeley
hell no but ucla
um good schools by the way yeah um but i
will tell you that his generation is
very aware of wokeness and they want to
be able to maintain their conservative
values in college and they push back
against
a lot of the teachers that they've had
in high school and they come and they
talk to their parents and they say
i'm not going to be indoctrinated so i
think because of social media because
because this is a generation that's
grown up with social media we didn't
because there's so much more out there
that kids can read on their own
again i go back to the word independent
as long as you tell your children just
because some somebody says something to
you and they appear to be in a position
of authority that doesn't make it true
you have to go back and check for
yourself but i will say that i am
pleasantly surprised with this
generation of 17 18 19 year olds who are
aware that they're trying to be
manipulated mentally yeah but you said
something very powerful right now
danielle so uh uh what percentage of
parents do you think tell their kids
listen to your teachers listen to what
your teacher has to say questions listen
to your teacher okay you know what i'm
gonna answer your question please i'm
gonna answer your question because texas
is not you i said majority i i
understand go forward i understand
texas has been on the receiving end so
is florida okay of um of people escaping
high state income tax flux of people
coming in yes but what we're starting to
hear in texas also from californians who
are coming in is i don't even want to
flirt with critical race theory coming
into my schools i'm moving to get away
from this from this education system
period and i want to raise my family in
an area where they can think
independently you know what that says
though it's not just an economic
decision to leave california is what i'm
saying no no but that's two things so
the question was an answer but i'm going
to come back to the question but here's
what i just got from what you just said
what you just said is the following
think about the people in new york
jersey illinois california that don't
want to leave that they're hopeful that
it's going to change the people they
need to stay are leaving let me say this
one more time
like you know what i'm saying like
imagine you're living in california like
dude i can't believe my family's here my
aunt's here my mom's here my grandma's
yeah i can't leave this place well guess
what this ain't flipping because those
people are leaving to states like texas
and florida yeah and it's killing their
tax base of course it is but the
question i'm asking is the following
what percentage of parents tell their
kids listen to your teachers i don't
know
i think it's a lot lower percentage than
it was i agree i agree with that but
it's still a high number it is but you
know what because you have a different
view of public school teachers unions
over the last year and a half they have
done this to themselves so i think that
number is going down very very quickly i
mean when you have andrew yang come out
and say enough with the new york public
enough with the new york teachers unions
let the parents go back to work let the
kids go back to school you're taking a
whole year of these kids education in
very formative years when somebody like
andrew yang is saying enough with the
unions i mean that's powerful because
people like that have a voice that
speaks not just to conservatives but to
a lot of americans so again i think the
unions have done americans in general
parents in general a great favor over
the last two years because now we know
that they're not advocates for our kids
at all they're advocates for themselves
what they say what they call parents
this week you saw the big controversy
going back and forth uh did you see that
no no no no no but i can only imagine
yeah it was it was
where you know they're trying to control
you know teach critical race theory
parents are coming out saying you ain't
bringing crt to my school listen just
because i don't uh support crt doesn't
mean i'm racist i don't want to talk
about this and they say well the parents
are the real threat and we have to get
involved and do this and no no we are
not the threat then they apologize
because of what they wrote then another
position anyways it's a mess right now
because school boards think about the
school boards across the country are
they ran by people on the left or the
right left well left 100
majority so you know you know what i
mean i
i live in the wrong schools they're
borderline militant but you know you
know what i will say to you you know
what i will say
and we send our kids to military schools
the opposite end of the spectrum i was
thinking about this this morning when
i'm driving down here when you know when
people make the argument they say
you should have half your board should
be women and men you should the board
should be your administration it should
be men
women and you know gay community
representation for every community you
know what i say to that i said no
problem you know what that should happen
let's apply it everywhere fifty percent
of professors should be conservative no
no no no no no no no no no no we should
do that i think you're right let's do
that fifty percent of the board of all
the school boards in america should be
around that's a great line why don't we
do that
let's
okay okay ideologically inclusive shall
we yeah go for it they would never
support that are you kidding me they
would never support i mean that's what's
wrong with so many of these not just
educational institutions but that's
right what that's what's wrong with
places like the federal reserve you put
up 786 phds in economics in one
organization you know what you're going
to get the same frigging thought you
know i'll tell you one of the best
moments for me in this past year is my
older daughter is a teacher she
graduated from pepperdine and she's a
great great teacher and she got a job in
a private school and i'm so relieved
that she doesn't have to be in the la
unified
teachers union i'm so grateful and it's
such a different world such a different
experience when you're in that in a
private school environment you're so
lucky i was in santa monica a few weeks
ago filming with the great jeffrey
gundlach thank you very much if you
didn't watch that episode please do go
check it out um but i i i i was having a
conversation with a parent
of kids in private school do you know
you know you probably know that they
didn't let the private schools open the
la teachers union wouldn't let private
schools that want it to open with safety
protocols open they said if we have to
be closed the public school system has
to be closed down so does the private
school system i'm like that that can't
be legal that just can't be legal i mean
when you hear these things that are
coming out of california it's the
madness and the parents are still paying
these enormous tuitions and their kids
can't even be in the classroom yeah you
know can i make a point on this musk
situation here you know the thing that
really gets me and i know a lot of other
people is it's just a plan like this is
just so insulting and it's so
unimaginative if you think about it
because they're asking us to believe
that if you did receive 50 billion
dollars from elon musk you would know
what to do with it right you could solve
hunger what does that mean that they
would get one meal a day every single
hungry person and the rest would be red
tape or whatever we don't no one trust
them that they would know what to do
with this money the other thing too is
obscene wealth or the mega wealthy has
almost become a new sport in this
country like people go to forbes like
they used to go to box scores in the
sporting videos you know who's gone up
elon musk went up 36 billion on monday
because of the hurts deal right so it's
unbelievable so
if i was an uber wealthy person i think
they'd be a little hesitant about this
being out there so much because hell at
vt post we could do a story on it every
single day there's something new in that
world of the mega wealthy and it's
interesting it's fun it's fun stories to
do um and here's the other thing a guy
like elon musk for instance how liquid
is he like if you try to give him a 50
billion dollar tax bill it's not like he
can pay that i mean it's not like he has
that lying around and the final thing is
could you imagine if they forced elon
musk to pay 50 billion or a zuckerberger
some of these guys what would that do to
the stock price it would kill everybody
that's an investor in tesla so it's just
so unimaginative and so insulting when
they come up with these ideas because
they grab headlines they're catchy but
it just shows how small thinkers that
yeah and then manchin says
excuse me
and then we move on to the next plan and
that's exactly what happened yesterday
manchin said
excuse me and then it had to get all
dropped bye-bye
i've two things on this which is
interesting because
part of the key point that he says is
who is best at capital allocation
government or entrepreneurs
is indeed what it comes down to and i
completely agree with that like first of
all the whole tax bill is the slippery
slope if you're gonna start where
they're gonna stop it right once they
get the door open they'll swing it wide
open and blow a hole in a hole in the
wall while they're at it so
no doubt that what piggybacking on what
tom saying is that you need to have what
is it for it's not a blank check what is
it being used for and at that point it
could be like okay
and that's where uh donations and and
and coming in and being able to donate
your money of oh i see what this is
going for this is going for xyz i want
to be a part of that i want to invest in
that or i want to i want to gift you
guys this the other thing is with with
hunger which is interesting is that in
the world right now there's more obese
people than there are
nurture
nourished nourished
and every year there's 108 billion
pounds of food in the u.s alone
that is a hundred and sixty billion
dollars in food and
actually surprisingly it's almost 40 of
the food in the u.s yeah i mean there
are some great restaurant tours out
there that make an effort every single
day they close to get the food banks the
extra food as opposed to throwing it
away
i mean it's
it's it's an effort you've got to have
you've got to have an extra employee on
hand to do it but it's the right thing
to do instead of putting it into the
dumpster stop and think about it when
you roll through a restaurant or
something high-end like that you're
going where does all this food go like
have you ever been to italy it's it's a
fun little place you know nice little
italian vibe there but they have so much
food on display and you're going where
does this go if someone's not buying it
right do they throw it out most of the
time they do yeah here's a good tip if
you go to randy's donuts at the end of
the day you could probably get a dozen
if you pay for one because they just
throw them out we've been there if they
closed that eight they'll just hey you
need a dozen donuts yeah go there right
this is economics 101 it closes yeah
save that money maybe the biggest tip of
the day you just gave me yeah legendary
tip right because it changed people's
lives go to the donut shop right before
it closed because that put 16 cents into
context so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]